vn und chinas neue seidenstraße ist
unzweifelhaft ein gewaltiges projekt
ausgaben in millionenhöhe
um china auf der straße der schiene sie
dem wasser und über pipelines mit der
welt zu vernetzen
von china durch zentralasien nach europa
afrika nahost südostasien und indien
ist das ehrgeizige projekt ist bereits
sein eigenes ökosystem
hallo ich bin haslinger armin willkommen
auf dem neuen super highway des handels
chinas neuer seidenstraße
[Musik]
unsere reise beginnt hier in mumbai der
symbolischen eingangspforte der größten
demokratie der welt indien das land
steht der neuen seidenstraße jedoch
alles andere als offen gegenüber zwei
gewaltige volkswirtschaften mit mehr als
einem drittel der weltbevölkerung und
einer langen geschichte des
wechselseitigen misstrauens
es ist nachvollziehbar dass indien wegen
seines rapide wachsenden nachbarn der
indien an sich bereits überholt hat
beunruhigt ist nicht möchte dass china
die gesamte asiatische infrastruktur
plant
gleichzeitig könnte indien von chinas
infrastrukturprojekten in der region
profitieren
viele länder die sich an projekten der
neuen seidenstraße beteiligen wie zb sri
lanka thron in eine schuldenfalle zu
tappen um unsere nachbarn pakistan die
malediven und sri lanka haben unserer
ansicht nach ein besonders hohes risiko
der überschuldung
sie sind seit jeher gegen china und der
geteilten grenze besorgt ebenso
bezüglich pakistan
sollten sie also wegen der neuen
seidenstraße besorgt sein sie werden
wohl besonders bei angrenzenden ländern
die sie historisch beeinflussten besorgt
sein
sei es wegen der eisenbahn nach neapel
einem hafen in bangladesch oder sri
lanka oder
dem chinesisch pakistanischen
wirtschafts korridor
[Musik]
kernpunkt der ablehnung indiens ist das
größte projekt der neuen seidenstraße
der chinesische pakistanische
wirtschafts korridor der sich aus einer
der westlichsten städte chinas durch das
umkämpfte kaschmir bis zum arabischen
meer zählt
der wirtschafts korridor ist bisher die
größte einzelne komponente der neuen
seidenstraße und bedeutet pakistan feel
china
konnte in kurzer zeit beispielsweise den
mangel an energie und elektrizität in
pakistan lindern
daher bedeutet dass pakistan vielen ist
aber auch für china wichtig denn
pakistan ist seit langem mit china
verbündet
ein widerpart zu indien mit zugang zum
arabischen meer an der grenze zur
politisch brisanten chinesischen provinz
xinjiang
der erfolg bedeutet also beide parteien
vielen
mache ich als unternehmen eine
fehlinvestition muss ich das wegstecken
und weiter machen eine regierung hat
aber nicht nur finanzielle sorgen
sie lanka beispielsweise vermietet
seinen hafen der direkt neben indien und
an einer großen internationalen fracht
route liegt
auch im pakistanischen hafen von gaza
wurde eine milliarde investiert obwohl
der ebenfalls nicht aussichtsreich ist
man sichert sich also heute diese fracht
helfen die langfristig jedoch auch
anderen zwecken dienen können
dschibuti welches china ebenfalls viel
geld schuldet stellt dem chinesischen
militär nur mehr einen teil des landes
für militärische basen zur verfügung es
sind definitiv strategische interessen
im spiel
der korridor durch pakistan ist
wirtschaftlich nicht einleuchtend denn
er führt über den himalaya von china
nach pakistan nicht allzu praktisch
das wird wie ein strategisches manöver
chinas also verstehe ich warum sich
indien umzingelt fühlt wenn china
infrastruktur in pakistan einrichtet
das schienennetz indiens reicht
eineinhalb mal um die erde und befördert
offiziell 8 milliarden passagiere im
jahr
nimmt man jene hinzu die die gewaltige
nation inoffiziell bereisen sind es noch
viel mehr zu
stoßzeiten drängen sich bis zu 7000
fahrgäste in zügen die für 1700
ausgelegt sind
das system ist veraltet und dringend
sanierungsbedürftig
die stimmung in indien wandelt sich
deswegen große investitionen seitens der
ip beispielsweise in den nahverkehr in
mumbai wo wir gerade sind das ist nur
ein beispiel für zusammenarbeit
bezüglich der infrastruktur indiens
das hätte aber auch ohne die neue
seidenstraße passieren können
dass sich indiens nachbarn allen voran
sri lanka nepal und pakistan mit so viel
begeisterung an der neuen seidenstraße
beteiligen liegt auch am versagen
indiens sich mit seinen nachbarn zu
vernetzen
indien betreibt aus historischen gründen
kaum handel mit pakistan
konnte jedoch auch jahrzehntelang keine
bedeutsame infrastruktur verbindung nach
nepal einrichten
auch nach bangladesch gibt es kaum
verbindungen weder für energie noch für
den warenverkehr das gleiche gilt auch
für sri lanka
mumbai war früher teil der alten
seidenstraße auf
den hafen welcher der größte des landes
ist empfiehlt die hälfte des
containerverkehrs auch das westliche
marinekommando indiens ist hier ansässig
im westen liegen das arabische meer
pakistan und der nahe osten östlich
liegt der reichtum südost asiens und
etwas weiter china
[Musik]
manche pleiten wie beispielsweise in sri
lanka komme nicht überraschend man
vergleicht die wirtschaftsleistung die
investitionen und die projekte
in hambantota landen nur ein oder zwei
schiffe pro woche kein wunder dass das
projekt scheiterte das gleiche könnte im
kader passieren auch hier wurde eine
milliarde investiert
wenn die empfänger nation in der neuen
seidenstraße mit china angemessene
konditionen aushandeln wollen gibt es
kaum gegenangebote das war chinas großer
vorteil
sie bieten nicht nur die finanzierung
sondern auch das know how wodurch sie
ein überzeugendes gesamtpaket anbieten
die empfängerländer müssen aber
bezüglich der finanzierung aufpassen
als nächstes begeben wir uns von indien
nach zentralasien und folgen chinas
neuer seidenstraße
in kasachstan ist eines der länder die
am meisten von der neuen seidenstraße
profitieren könnten die hauptstadt nur
sultan ist das verwaltungszentrum des
größten binnenland der welt es liegt
zwischen russland und china und ist der
mittelpunkt eines bio politischen wie
wirtschaftlichen balance akt
[Musik]
die hochmoderne statt nur sultan wurde
durch den ölreichtum der vorherrschenden
wirtschaft zentralasiens finanziert
die stadt feiert ihr 20 jähriges
bestehen und den geburtstag des bis 2019
einzigen präsidenten
nursultan nasarbajew war präsident des
landes seit kasachstan 1991 unabhängig
wurde hier eröffnet er nach fünf jahren
planung spektakulär nur sultans
finanzzentrum um die kapitalmärkte der
region zu vernetzen
genau wie das land auch seine rolle als
entscheidende binnen abschnitt der neuen
seidenstraße akzeptiert hat
das herzstück der wirtschaftspolitik der
regierung ist diversifizierung die
erschaffung neuer wirtschaftszweige
sowohl in der industrie als auch bei
dienstleistungen insbesondere
finanzdienstleistungen
wir wollen das finanzzentrum der region
werden um die wirtschaft in der region
aufzubauen und sie in kasachstan in
einer guten position dieses ziel zu
erreichen
wir sind das erste land auf dem weg von
china nach europa und haben bereits
infrastruktur aufgebaut bevor die neue
seidenstraße ins leben gerufen wurde
2500 kilometer schienen verbinden den
osten und den westen des landes was ich
seit beginn der initiative als praktisch
erwies
wir waren vorbereitet und arbeit nun mit
china an der umsetzung verschiedener
projekte
insgesamt sind in kasachstan 58 projekte
im wert von 28 milliarden dollar geplant
sie sind teil der neuen seidenstraße
aber dienen nicht nur dazu es ist eine
weitreichende wirtschaftliche
partnerschaft
es ist für uns besonders von vorteil da
wir ein durchgangsland sind
damit lässt sich viel geld verdienen
wir haben den 3000 kilometer langen
kasachischen teil des super highway von
china nach westeuropa fertiggestellt was
für die strecke bis zur russischen
grenze etwa drei milliarden dollar
gekostet hat
einen neuen hafen warten
der weg führt über das meer nach
aserbaidschan und georgien
von dort aus in die türkei und zum
mittelmeer an und von dort aus weiter
nach westen
ein weiterer weg ist die eisenbahn von
am kaspischen meer durch turkmenistan
und iran zum persischen golf
wir haben also vielfältige handelswege
eingerichtet und verschiedene
alternativen parat
nach norden westen und auch noch 7
einkauf an der kasse chinesischen grenze
ist der größte umschlagplatz der welt in
planung er entsteht in der kasachischen
steppe nicht weit vom sogenannten
eurasischen punkt der unzulänglichkeit
entfernt denn am weitesten vom nächsten
ozean entfernten punkt der welt nahezu
alles was von china aus auf der schiene
nach westen gelangt nimmt diesen weg
[Musik]
china trägt 50 prozent der kosten
jetzt können züge aus dem osten chinas
zuerst china und dann kasachstan
durchqueren und den nur zwei wochen nach
istanbul gelangen
und wir wollen diese reisezeit noch
verringern
vielleicht zwölf oder zehn tage
dieser teil der erde war
jahrhundertelang das herz der
seidenstraße
jetzt da die neue seidenstraße mit
schienen und asphalt wieder aufgebaut
wird wird kasachstan erneut das
entscheidende drehkreuz in eurasien sein
welche branchen werden in kasachstan
davon profitieren die seewege haben uns
ein wenig das rampenlicht gestohlen doch
so langsam geraten landwege wieder in
den blick
profitieren wird natürlich das bauwesen
aber auch die verarbeitung in der
petrochemie deren produkte für den
straßenbau benötigt werden und auch die
landwirtschaft und die
lebensmittelbranche werden profitieren
das container volumen das von china aus
kasachstan durchquert hat sich in den
letzten sieben jahren jährlich
verdoppelt die schätzung für 2020 liegt
bei zwei millionen container kasachstan
erwartet also transit gebühren in höhe
von fünf milliarden dollar im jahr
unweit des umschlagplatzes liegt die von
china und kasachstan so getaufte
internationale freihandelszone die
grenze wird auf beiden seiten von der
strategisch geplanten seidenstraßen
zwillingsstadt flankiert die aktuell
jedoch noch ein niemandsland ist
die während des kalten krieges war das
hier ein militärisches sperrgebiet die
tür im hintergrund markieren die grenze
die chinesische seite wurde fast
vollständig ausgebaut doch auch
kasachstan hat große pläne um aufzuholen
das ist das tor zum chinesischen markt
also beschlossen unsere regierungen die
einrichtung einer sonderwirtschaftszone
um das handels drehkreuz zu etablieren
zu zeiten der sowjetunion war es ein
flaschenhals
nun bauen wir es aus und den
warenverkehr in beide richtungen zu
verbessern
doch auch fünf jahre nach beginn der
planungen ist zumindest die kasachische
seite alles andere als fertig
manche halten kasachstan für den knoten
der die seidenstraße zusammenhält es
gibt jedoch noch probleme
wir haben die infrastruktur ausgebaut
und in enger zusammenarbeit mit unseren
nachbarn wie russland und belarus die
eurasische wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
eingerichtet
somit konnten wir sowohl zölle als auch
schienenverkehrs gebühren
vereinheitlichen und haben dadurch nicht
nur harte infrastruktur in form von 2500
kilometern schienen erschaffen sondern
auch die weiche infrastruktur verbessert
und handelshindernisse abgebaut
[Musik]
vom zentralasiatischen kasachstan geht
es nun nach südostasien auf unserer
reise entlang der neuen seidenstraße
[Musik]
die neue seidenstraße bietet den ländern
von asian gewaltige chancen da
infrastruktur der schlüssel zum
wirtschaftswachstum ist in indonesien
den philippinen myanmar laos malaysia
und thailand entstehen projekte im wert
von hunderten milliarden dollar um die
vernetzung zu verbessern
wenn die physische infrastruktur einmal
steht wirkt sich das positiv auf handel
und investitionen aus
das ist ein zentrales element der
wirtschaftlichen zukunft indonesien
ich bin sicher im kommenden jahr wird
die produktivitätssteigerung durch die
infrastrukturprojekte unser
wirtschaftswachstum antreiben
wir vergrößern unsere flughäfen nicht
weil wir uns mehr verkehr erhoffen
sondern weil sie bereits überfordert
sind
auch unsere häfen sind überfüllt und wir
verbessern im rahmen unserer bauprojekte
ebenfalls unsere straßen
zudem fördert das nicht nur die
vernetzung innerhalb unseres landes
sondern auch über die landesgrenzen
hinaus
wie viele nachbarstaaten investiert auch
thailand in die neue seidenstraße
mit chinas hilfe geben sie milliarden
aus um den osten des landes in einen
wirtschafts korridor zu verwandeln und
weitere milliarden für projekte wie
dieser hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke von
bangkok nach china
der mega bahnhof wird bangkoks drehkreuz
für schnellzüge sein richtung norden
durch laos nach china und richtung süden
durch malaysia nach singapur wobei
dieser teil des projekts in gefahr ist
zudem werden so die drei größten
flughäfen thailands an den wirtschafts
korridor im osten angebunden
das projekt soll nicht nur ein
beschleuniger für die vernetzung
innerhalb thailands sondern auch mit
anderen insbesondere benachbarten
ländern sein
im norden liegt china also ist es nur
folgerichtig dass wir den anschluss an
die neue seidenstraße suchen
es wird ein durchgängiger korridor der
von china im norden nach süden durch
thailand und nach ganz asien verläuft
jedes land muss seine eigenen interessen
wahren und sicherstellen dass es sich
die darlehen leisten kann
[Musik]
nicht nur jetzt sondern auch für
zukünftige generationen
unsere zweite alleen sind eines in höhe
von 62,5 millionen dollar für einen damm
und eines für die städtische
wasserversorgung in höhe von 200
millionen dollar
aktuell handeln wir ein größeres
darlehen in höhe von etwa 2,8 milliarden
dollar für ein eisenbahnprojekt aus
es dient der verbesserung bestehender
bahninfrastruktur die in schlechtem
zustand ist
in indonesien haben wir bereits ein
system für wichtige
infrastrukturprojekte eingerichtet
entscheiden wir dann welche projekte wir
gerne in die neue seidenstraße ein
ändern würden
die umsetzung ist das größte problem
von den angepeilten 50 konnten wir
bisher erst neun projekte umsetzen wir
haben also noch viel vor uns
die finanzierung steht auch wenn wir
einige anforderungen erfüllen müssen um
sie zu erhalten
um überschaubare kosten
und die gibt es zuhauf nicht nur bei der
neuen seidenstraße
indonesien durchläuft gerade reformen
und viele infrastruktur projekte haben
regulatorische probleme
das 4 1 lizenznahme arbeitskräfte auch
beim landerwerb gibt es probleme
wir müssen eine vielzahl lokaler
probleme lösen um größtmögliche gewinne
zu realisieren
für china führt ein weiterer bedeutender
abschnitt durch myanmar wo lokale
probleme viele fragen aufwerfen
das land grenzt an china indien und
bangladesch bietet nicht nur eine route
zum indischen ozean sondern auch über
land zum westen des indischen
subkontinents
es gibt in vielerlei hinsicht bedenken
große infrastrukturprojekte häufen große
schulden an die regierung ist wegen der
überschuldung des landes besorgt die die
nächste generation treffen könnte
das ist etwas gutes denn so bauen wir
nicht einfach auf gedeih und verderb
ohne unser budget zu bedenken
nach jana unter militärischer herrschaft
ist mir maß infrastruktur dringend
reformbedürftig und somit ein ideales
ziel der neuen seidenstraße auf
der anderen seite steht die frage wie
sich die projekte auf das technische
know-how und die arbeitskräfte im land
auswirken werden
von chinas langjähriger unterstützung
mehrmals bekam die bevölkerung in der
vergangenheit in vielen fällen kaum
positive effekte mit
das waren die perspektiven indiens
zentralasiens und süd ost asiens zur
neuen seidenstraße
ich bin herzlich armin vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]